字幕志愿者 李宗盛
李宗盛
欢迎收看赵华
我是赵华
我是阿伦
现在市场上最想要问的东西就是
打完美
有机会
哪个事情打完美
角啊
除了打角之外
我觉得比较意外的是
美伊又在讲和谈
重點是股市還吃這一套
油價還回落
沒錯
就是這件事情
竟然可以Huckle這麼久之後
大家繼續買單
沒錯
你覺得原因是什麼
我覺得原因是
大家可能現在就是需要一個利多
大家情緒比較低迷一點點
突然有一個小利多出來
大家就會放大去烘台股價
是 因為前幾天的成交量也比較低
今天也稍微放大
有到8000億的量
而且今天上漲的加速
可以說是百花齊放
反而前一天
這個街棒演出的傳產金融
今天是壓力比較大一點
凌晨 我們要等回答了
這一次會不會打破魔咒
感覺開始在反應
我覺得還可以吧
對啊
因為我們昨天有特別聊到一件事
回答每一次法說都超乎市場預期
但是股價都是跌
這一次遇到了油價跌
股價開始恢復上漲了
能不能上演大逆轉
我覺得這一次看起來是滿有急的
所以我樂觀看待
要賭嗎
不用賭
我們看晚上睡庭就知道了
那我們先看這件事情
一方面伊朗跟阿曼這邊
也有做了一些動作
他們要去臨時航線給它開出來
要排水雷
不過商船是可以通行的
軍艦不行
另外一個美國
有把水域內的水雷都大致清除了
然後呢外交官準備返回以色列
沙國黎巴嫩跟伊拉克
就開始要做一些談判的動作
那水雷可以再丟回去啊
對不對
然後他們也可以官員再送回來啊
對啊
所以到時候如果又發生
你講了這些事情嘛
對啊
這個就變紅色的啊
然後這個也變紅色的啊
我希望打完
打完我們的腳就真的打完了吧
欸...確實啦
但是目前看起來好像也沒什麼
可以很明確的一個狀態啊
大家就是零食又利多
零食又利空的反應
所以我也只能說
我們就
對嘛 等一下來賓會講
我們要有堅定的信心
但是我們要把眼光
可能就放到科技股的身上了
主場又回來了
沒錯 我們這個美債殖利率
30年級跌下來
可能科技股就開始走一個反彈
那也帶動了今天的
其實昨天台詞夜盤漲400點
早上開盤的時候
覺得奇怪怎麼那麼弱
被沒收
怎麼那麼弱
對
可是盤中就發動了一個出量的攻擊
所以我覺得非常不錯
另外一個這個就是Virarubin
有一些相關的利多Groke要出來了
其實今天滿多Virarubin相關的事情
就感覺他回答財報以前好熱鬧
是的 所以我覺得這些
也有一些推升股價的狀態
像是他說吞吐量會是
這個GB300的30倍
資料的吞吐量
沒錯 另外一個Token的速度
推論的速度會快4倍
所以我觉得也很不错
那整个呢
目前推论会变成是一个主战场
过去会是认为是
我要扩大基础建设
我东西要越大越好
越多越满
那现在呢
现在大家讲效率
你可以不用大
但你要快
对
天下武功为快不破
是的
速度要快
延迟要够低
成本期望可能能够降低
那补齐就是低延迟的
这些推论的拼图
就是Varubin计算加GORP的高速生成
就是它已经原本是
GIGS 这会
现在两边各专精
那就会变得比较有效率一点
再来成本下降
就会激发需求去做增加
另外台厂的售汇时间
就会相对去拉长
所以这些硬体厂
鸿海拱达伟创
基本上就会是售汇的个股
当然鸿海可能大家现在认为
2027年会是最售汇的一个公司
这个我觉得对长线
台湾的硬体厂商来讲
应该就会是利多
这个成本下降真的还蛮重要的
因为现在零组件都在涨价
所以他一定要想办法
這邊有一些東西
是可以讓總體下來的效率超過成本
是的
所以這個就看後面的狀況了
當然這個我覺得對AI的發展來講
應該會是利多
當然還有另外一個利多就是
Anthropic
所以要充施IPO
原本有SpaceX
就是什麼最大的IPO個股
地表最大IPO
對 這個有可能要超過了
地表又來了一個更大IPO
所以大家現在錢其實真的很多
我們地表真的要產生很多東西
最近更新速度越來越快
當然我們9月也幫大家
稍微整理一下關鍵的大事
因為8月最後一個禮拜
如果我們現在已經要準備發動
9月要接棒就要有很多事情了
是的 我們看到的就是代爾
代爾大家記憶有存
就上一次公布財報的時候
那個價格 大標
對 然後也帶動台灣的
伺服器代工那一塊
就是比較中後段那一塊
也是標了一大波
另外還有像博通又要來了
然後半導體展
所以看有沒有機會
对 有没有一些提前发酵力多
那产品发表会很重要吗
苹果的产品发表会
其实好像蛮重要的
我已经可以帮他下一个注解了
了无新意
是的
就每一次媒体都这样说
对
然后再来就我们最重要的
台积电8月营收
对
然后制造设备站
日本的
是的
那另外还有美光财报
是
美光财报
好
OK
这个记忆体相关的
其实我觉得也蛮重要的
对
好
然后929
还有OpenAI的开发者大会
对
这中间好像漏了一些东西
其实我刚好在看
因为没有联准会升息
对但我想一想
因为科技是科技业
所以应该也不会加进来
因为你在乎的是联准会
对因为我记得9月要升降息
但不过没关系
我们跟大家讲就是
这些相关的重点的一些数字
如果是好的
那我们刚好说到
现在8月其实有一些利多出境
因为8月10号公布完营收了
然后8月也讲完了这个
法縮了
所以有點空窗期
那如果這些能夠帶來利多
我覺得股市表現
應該就會慢慢的
有再墊高的機會
好 當然兩件大事
一個是中秋節的連假
這次可以連到四天
然後再來就是
艾倫的生日也在這個月
他不好意思說
我來幫他說
放個一個月吧
好 OK 好 我們看到大盤
大盤的表現
沒有這種禮物
OK 好 大盤的表現呢
我們昨天有說到
回測月線
加前低
然后打了第二只脚
小脚
对
那这个区间呢
我们昨天有说嘛
你要今天如果能够做一个突破
那我觉得就是一个
非常强势的表现
今天突破了
重点是量能呢
虽然还没有到8500
但也有个8200
我觉得OK
就是上涨的时候呢
是有放量的
所以过关了吗
我就给过
接下来要挑战的
就是这个地方嘛
这个前高嘛
那有两个状态
一个呢
当然最好的
我们这边先画出来
然后这里打
然後就做突破
突破就挑戰前高
這應該就沒問題了
可是有個狀況
我們就稍微注意一下
如果高點沒有過
那下來的話呢
就會注意要變成一個大區間震大
對 所以目前大概就是兩個狀態
但今天這一根的整個表現
我覺得是非常不錯的
就是你站會全部均線
然後你突破小箱形
然後成交量放出來
所以多頭是有進攻意願的
對 那如果這邊呢
今天回答稍微講好聽一點
然後接下來Jackson Ho
這個華許講好聽一點
那我觉得这很有机会
在近期内就去挑战这个
甚至是去做突破
好 回答一定会讲好听的
市场买不买单啦
就是买不买单
所以真的不要来那个吗
拆一下吗
不用 好 我们要继续跟他贵买
好啦 贵买也是一样的道理啦
就是今天都是突破了这个箱形
手足月线突破箱形
那刚刚大盘要挑战前高
那贵买要先挑战季线
因为季线还没站回来
再来呢 季线站上才去挑战这个
那如果行政应该任志行
其实跟大盘一样
我們就是挑戰前面的六月的高點
所以這邊大家可以再陸續看
有沒有有機會偏得更樂觀的狀態
我覺得已經偏樂觀了
有沒有更樂觀
就是前高要做突破
這個是大家會需要觀察的
好 再來我們看到的就是這個台積電
台積電今天又開機走高了
其實不錯啦 對
那也創下了這個
這一段時間以來的一個短線新高
但是一樣 我們就持續觀察
2450如果做突破
基本上我覺得大盤那個前高
應該就要做突破
好 我們有秘密武器台積電
只要它往上攻
你说指数要创高
真的应该没有太难
是的
对 所以我觉得台积电
今天也开始小放量
没有到很大量
但是如果这边做突破
量能持续去增温
我觉得大盘就不用太担心
蓄积能量 蓄积能量
没错 这边就盘整
等待一个更好的状态出现
那我们来看一下鸿海
因为刚刚提到Groove 3
它怎么长成这样
对 虽然它长成这样
怎么了
没有啊
它什么时候你又走回去原点了
你不知道整個伺服器代工
這一陣子很弱嗎
因為我都一直在看
中小型還有像
傳載航海王什麼的
對
這一票像是
鴻海廣達偉創
然後還有像是
人保其實還算強
人保算強
他比較弱後補漲
可是像鷹業達技嘉
其實前一陣子都有
下來一下下
對 那鴻海是
人家那個是
上去很多下來一下
鴻海是上去也不多
下來也不多
就在這個區間震盪
但人家今天不錯
今天有站回五日均線
所以這邊在持續的主體中
也是一样
今天成交量其实不太够的
所以能够先慢慢站为全部均线
然后慢慢量放出来
这个前高才有机会去做突破
那才有机会形成一个大底部
那目前是主体阶段
所以鸿海的我们刚刚提到嘛
那基本面我觉得明年
应该都持续没问题
可是技术面上
可能要有更好的转折讯号出现
才是有动能出现了
就只能当价值股先放着了
对不对
没错没错没错
所以这个是目前鸿海的形态
都还是比较温
温一点
温温的
所以可能要点耐心
好 刚刚我们觉得
大盘现在的形态
确实走得蛮好看的
虽然艾文他不是很想跟我去讨论
到底这一次回答能不能逆转胜
可是今天真的看到很多
回答相关的新闻
不晓得大家有没有留意到
里面有一条
其实讲到的是跟PCB的规格有关
所以下一段节目
我们就会来好好的聊一下
到底PCB现在占整个Vairroobin
或是下一代的Vairroobin Ultra
它的角色是什么呢
有什么样的东西
可以值得来做留意
当然如果大家需要今天所有的图卡资料
记得订阅一下赵华艾伦说的YouTube频道
我们会免费放在首页的贴文栏
那我们等一下就来拆解PCB的密码
好来
Groghpx
我们到底要认识多少名词
好累
对啊
Grogh是什么东西
就是Grogh
Grogger 還要3
要裹3次
對 裹裹裹裹
裹裹裹裹
好 OK 青蛙
好 全面浪產
台系材料其實是有受惠的
所以大家可以發現
其實今天的PCB上中油
表現是不錯的
當然板類也不錯
金像電 星星琴碩
尾盤都滿強勢的
今天板類是有起色的
本來滿好的
所以我覺得還不錯
那這整個規格的提升
會帶動就是CCL跟HVLP4
同波還有PCB相關的材料升級
那目前是採一個混搭的方案
M9搭配的是Q布
M8搭配的是Rodicay 2的這個波纖布
有不同的組合
所以這個東西拆開
會變成這樣一層一層一層的東西
沒錯 所以這個就
大家又開始討論的就是
PCB感覺不管你是哪一個東西
它就是一定是基底
它那個基底一定要在
就是升級這件事情又來了是的 所以整個的一個PCB的上中有間的表現呢其實是蠻勢的包含了就是台光電不過最強的是三哥今天連貿是漲停的
第二根
因為連貿聽說是比較不受規格影響的
跟著漲價就對
而且它很便宜 股價
那目前來說
台光電已經取得M9材料認證
然後並進行M10的認證
是的 那京區其實台灣就獨有這一家
所以他有他自己的獨有的地位
但是很多的官員朋友就說
他都是獨有了獨家了
他的股價怎麼沒有獨家感
沒錯 這個大家的感覺我也懂
奇怪 股價怎麼不太會動
不過等一下還是幫大家解析一下技術面上
然後德宏就是Q步
不過德宏確實最近的股價也比較辛苦
那富橋最近的股價就不太辛苦
最近股價要創歷史新高
今天盤中一度快漲停板
好 這個是相關的一些個股
所以我們今天也幫大家稍微再繼續
一個大方向的統整
好漂亮啊
對 今天都紅通通的
今天整個 當然今天行情不錯啦
那整個EPS也都紅色的
至少看來 對啦
自己是用紅色的
沒人賠錢
對 沒人賠錢
所以目前這幾位在今天都沒有全部
但有一些個股陸續的在今天的成交量
都是稍微放比較大一點點
所以我覺得它有開始要進攻的訊號
而且比較整齊
是 比較整齊
然後各股的成交量
稍微陸續地在做一個小放大
我們現在看到的就是台藥
台光店比較貴一點點
而且已經創歷史新高過了
是的 那連茂呢 下不來
所以我們就來看一下
卡在中間的二哥台藥
不過台藥可能就會有面臨到
因為像連茂可能就把一些中地界市場吃走了
是的
台光店一定是最高階要幹嘛
他都一定領先
那台藥就要追
他就有點夾在中間
要上不上要下不下
但也可以啦
他也是陆续的
有在做一个M10认证
那只不过
前一阵子这一波的行情
哇 他就一个人很憔悴
然后憔悴到破千
跌了一千块
那目前来说呢
这一波反弹行情
他这一波也很强
那这一波是大家一起反弹
可是呢
到现在还在反弹的
只剩下连帽
那目前来说
今天你看这两天
成交量都开始在陆续的
有没有到爆大量
但有陆续的小出量
小出量过程中
来到月线的位置
那今天也破坏了下降趋势线
所以我觉得这个形态上
跟这个成交量上
大家短线上就可以开始好好注意了
因为停车点很好抓
我就月线跟昨天的低点跌破
那我就出场了
可是呢如果今天
再拉回全部均线
其实今天差一点也有啦
实际均线差一点站上
但如果这边我们能够反弹上来
甚至能够过高
拉一个N字形
然后去挑战前高
那我觉得这个赚培比
应该就值得去好好注意一下
突然这个图啊
它本来这样弯下去觉得
结果你画一个N字形
突然就漂亮起来
因为这两天其实
像昨天其实我觉得很漂亮的原因是
很多个股都拉下引线
然后呢
有拉下引线之外呢
因为它是先杀后拉嘛
所以有一些个股量能都有放出来
那就是等于底部放量的下引线嘛
那今天行情又不错
所以有延续拉两根红K的
我觉得都可以稍微注意一下
是一个好的讯号
尤其像这种差一点站为全部均线的
接下来就是等一个过高
如果高点能够做突破
那我觉得这个行情就至少先挑战前高
再来看有没有机会创历史新高
再来看到下一位呢
旧市京剧了
他为什么可以涨的又是横盘
因为说实话不管这个PCB
用在哪一带的Railroobin之类的
他同伯都是一直听到要他
对啊
股价就是寡赞
重点是他这一波跌还很凶
600跌到破300
他前面是700多抱歉
不好意思
700多跌到200多
接近300
所以它快3的数字
那这一波呢
当然也有反弹
但是你可以发现
谈到这个地方
很多个股啊
创历史新高的
那反弹5、60%以上的
季线都站不稳
这条季线都站不稳
这个季线目前在接近500块
480几块的位置
所以它也要先挑战季线去创高
才有机会往更高的路走
那不过呢
今天一样
我们都帮它找这种
这个量蛮漂亮的
当然这里也有一次
那这里也有一次呢
我们要观察是什么重点
是这个最大量的高点
要有一个收盘价的突破
这里曾经有一次想挑战
但失败了
失败
对 那今天又想要来挑战
目前没过
那目前没过要注意哦
明天是不是又要下来
然后再继续做一个区间整理
所以大家这边可以留意的是什么
当我在这边做一个区间震荡
如果我是抱持有耐心的人
我的停顺点就是抓这个前低
有跌破的时候
那后面让他盘整
可是我比较追求有效率一点点
那也不怕买贵的朋友
那就是这个高点
确定有个收盘价站上
再来去做介入
因为这也是大乡型
如果能够突破
那这个行情后续
应该会有一段向上的延伸
所以目前来说
京区它在目前的
这个区间内做游走的时候
就是要么你就抱着等了
要么呢
你就动能出现在操作了
那今天有先出量
所以明天有机会
但能不能过
回到收盘价再来确定
对这个是大家可以去观察的
京区
好 这个是在动能对不对
今天的话
它为什么体感温度会比较好
就是因为它的整体性比较强
然后就像你讲的
连续两天之后
那种动能感又跑出来了
对了
所以后续注意一下
然后再来看到最后就是尖点
赚针也是要嘛
而且也是消耗品嘛
而且赚针也是PCB各厂说
一定要技术提升
规格提升的
是的
单针
就那一根针
会越来越贵
毛利率会越来越高
而且需求越来越大
确实股价曾经也是很飙过
对那目前来说
我们跟京区遇到一样的状况
就是在一个大区间内做震荡
横盘的整理
那这个整理呢
你可以发现今天也放量了
所以跟京区一样
如果明天延续性能够拉出来
而且能够守到尾盘
然后站上这个大量的位置
这个都是一个形态上的转折
所以我们刚刚我们昨天有去讲的是
光宝科形态上的转折
那今天确实继续垫高
对 所以间点也是一样
跟京区观察方式是一样的
我在这边做横向整理
那我能够抓的停损
就是这低点跌破
那接下来能够发现动能
发生动能呢
就是这个大量的高点
要去做收盘价的站上
那届时应该就会有一段
新的行情可以做期待
所以呢目前来说
我们帮大家看的就是今天PCB
然后量能有在放大的
那明天可以好好观察
有没有进一步让形态
好转的现象出现
也许就有一段短线的动能
可以去做把握
好 所以其实我们今天选的股票
有一个特色哦
就是因为PCB接下来遇到
不管是辉达或其他的大厂
他们在规格上面
可能都会有一些调整
可是不管是钻针或铜箔
他们其实是有所谓的
寡占地位的
不容易被取代
所以他们现在在盘整
通常是给机会
以及刚刚讲到像台光电台
因为它所有高阶的
涨价的升级它都有
台药也在往这个部分做努力
所以我们有搭配
所谓产业的知识
那这边艾伦说的QR Code
也欢迎扫一下
因为明天它要送一个
比较特别的东西
它不是用全景图了
它今天帮大家
直接用技术形态来筛
就是有没有刚刚我们讲到的
低档转强动能
已经出现的PCB股票
大家可以锁股之后
练习一下
看看他们之后
是不是也顺势沿着技术形态往上走
如果又具备产业地位的话
会更优质
那广告回来的话
我们的大来宾今天很特别
他的诉求是什么呢
就叫做他永远都高持股
90%
不下车有信心
等一下会跟大家分享
他是如何有信心
未来两年三年AI依旧是主流
欢迎回来赵华
我想要问你
假如你现在
干嘛回眸一笑
怎么没有回眸一笑
请说
假如你现在是压满的
百分之百持股
那你会一直一直很有信心吗
然后市场跌了一万点
你还会很有信心吗
我应该就不会百分之百持股
所以可能这样问不太准
因为我不会用到百分百
真的吗
对
那你会用多少
算是你的上限
应该还是七成左右就上限了
就已经上限了
对不对
我也是
其实我都好习惯会留一些现金
持股比重没有办法因为你拉得很高
所以今天我们的大来宾
他就会来跟大家详细的讲解
为什么不管有没有遇到股灾
他有一个slogan
就叫做高持股
而且不要下車
好
我們先來歡迎她
就是我們的AI達人蔡明翰
趙華好 艾倫好 大家好
終於請到你了
因為說實話以前
我們趙華人說有請過明翰兩三次
但是真的不好請
因為現在如果大家一打開
網路的這些財經平台
就會發現
滿滿的都是明翰的臉
每個節目都有
對 明翰太受歡迎了
第一個當然是因為
在AI上面的研究
從兩三年開始
兩三年前開始就非常堅定的
在這條路上
他完完全全是台美股的大主流
另外你有一個slogan
高齒股有信心不下車
我現在看到很多喜歡你的人
都會複製這句話
去貼在很多粉專下面
為什麼會變成這樣的slogan
就像剛剛兩位講
說高齒股到七成就有點壓力
其實我有點嚇一跳
你太膽小了嗎
真的嗎
我個人因為我長期而言
我真的大部分都會維持在九成
甚至多一點點
然後就是九成上下跳動
我們先講清楚
我自己的定義持股
我都只有在講長線的部分
那就是長線我才有所謂的持股比例
短線就是進進出出 來來回回
而且最主要問題是因為
我短線的比例本來就不高
無論如何大概也不會高過一成
所以我不太在意短線那邊
我永遠講持股
我只在意我的長線
那我的長線確實
應該說自從有AI以來
等於二三年以來
我持股很少低於九成
那等於說
應該說我的動作只會加不太會減
因為我覺得一直覺得趨勢還在
那所以我常常講嚇不掉我
就是那些川普或什麼因子
我覺得其實對產業來講
其實影響都非常有限
所以我一直覺得
維持高持股是一個很重要的關鍵
好 明漢市CFA的Level 3
其實有過一段
非常非常精彩的求学历程
到考上这么难考的证照
到第三集
但是今天可能没有办法
跟大家详细的说明
如果大家有兴趣的话
可以去听我的Podcast
有聊过这一段
从几乎是不良少年吧
对不对
飙车足 打架
然后到可以去念到
九星山大学的财务分析硕士
然后还有这个特许分析师之照
反正简单的结论就是
我以前在退伍以前
我對讀書沒什麼太大的興趣
那到準備退伍找不到工作才發現
我到底想要做什麼
可是我其實我也沒有什麼概念
我老實說我對股票也沒有什麼太大的興趣
我那時候只愛玩而已
所以一直以來我父親上班就是穿西裝
然後每天朝九王我覺得看起來很羨慕很帥
所以我就想要找一個穿西裝上班的工作如此而已
那當時就覺得看起來好像看股票還不錯
然後就往這條路走
但是很明顯切點就從我
退伍之後就非常認真
每天等於說讀書的時間真的拉得很長
然後等到進入研究
最後到現在的工作
其實老實講工作是長的
一直以來都蠻長的
最後我常常講這個
你沒有點興趣
支撐不了這種所謂的長久的工作
就是我自己概念
所以當然後續來講就是
真的是自己的興趣
或者說我離開國泰
現在真的是等於說
自己想做什麼就做什麼
自己有選擇
那未來來講我覺得
最起碼我現在還是做得很開心
我對研究來講是我的興趣所在
好 離開國泰以後
真的是所有的節目
都瘋狂的在找民漢剛剛講說錄完我們的他晚上還要去弄自己的東西明天還有好幾場的錄影但是現階段除了剛剛講到的高持股有信心不下車
新法策略
以及有一些經驗分享是
我常常覺得你找到的資料好強
到底是怎麼找到的
除了我們每個月可以看到
什麼營收數據 總經數據之外
這邊可不可以教教大家
你是怎麼樣做決策的
還有為什麼可以分長線短線投資
然後長線的都不下車
好 我常常講就是
你要有信心
最重要的重點
你要先把長短線去做區分
那 尤其是無論是個股
或自己的部位
其實長短線
真的不要混在一起
我應該這樣講
這個是我以前
一直以來也常常犯的錯誤
尤其是我應該這樣講
接近20年的這個值
來包含我自己的投資
其實前半段
我也是跟一般投資人
沒什麼太大的差別
就是我也不會長短線區分
我也不知道什麼
反正現在市場什麼夯就買什麼
但後來慢慢的經過
一點點的長線投資之後發現
長線投資老實說
我個人覺得又輕鬆
而且重點輕鬆之外
重點是獲利其實
明顯的比短線好很多
這是我自己的問題
那我覺得投資人最主要的問題
就是他在長短線部分之外
還有一個很重要的關鍵點
一直每天要想盡辦法
把報酬率拉高
我常常講這也是我以前的關鍵
我們法人每天都有不同的訊息
然後都會覺得我自己的訊息
只有我知道我自己特別厲害
然後人家跟我講我就一定要去買
然後每個都買
然後呢不是說這些訊息不準或怎樣
但是我只能說訊息不可能
百分之百一定正確
你可能五個裡面你中三個
然後兩個失敗了
那加總是往上走的沒錯
但最重要的關鍵點
你經不起震盪
你只要中間無論川普說什麼
聯準會說什麼你就很緊張
然後你就趕快必須要去做檢碼
然後就是永遠在檢碼加碼當中
那我常常講就是說
你今天賺的錢其實投入了資金加上報酬率
每天想辦法要去拉高報酬率
我覺得應該我後來給自己的目標
都是以大盤為原則
我的目標只要打贏大盤就好
我不會想到說現在哪裡最強
我就一定要往哪裡衝
這是我自己的觀念
重點我剛剛提到
高持股是很重要的
我自己覺得這個工作
因為可以看到
從這個2023年
就我剛剛講的
就是從AI真的比較定義開始
到現在為止的收盤價
你可以看到加權指數
這三年來漲了兩倍以上
那這個如果0050漲了三倍
台積電漲了四倍
這什麼概念
就是你三年前丟100萬進去
其實你買台積電
現在已經賺了超過400萬
那我常常講的
Ewall以前確實進進出出
短線有信息
確實很快可以從100萬
就拉高到300 400萬
其實不難
但是中間只要遇到一狀況
瞬間可能又回到剩100萬
然後你可能這三年
又有點白做工的感覺
那你長線只要跟著指數
缺點是什麼
就是你的獲利的頻率
或者說你的速度
可能沒有感覺市場這麼行
你有時候可能比市場好一點
有時候比市場慢一點
但長期而言
重點是我後來
這樣的一個角度而已
如果最近的績效比大盤落後
其實我一點都不會緊張
我不會覺得
為什麼最近大家都買什麼賺大錢
只有我沒有
所以我個人覺得
其實對我來講
並不會有那麼大的壓力
只要時間拉長
趨勢正確
而且我要講一個概念
就是這是我自己後來感受到的經驗
就是我自己的一個心態的轉變
我剛講一開始
我進入法輪圈也是很重視
這個股價的一個部分
每天的漲跌
如自己手上的持股
到底每天收盤
可能漲了3塊錢
或漲了1.25%
那個小數點都會非常精確
因為每天非常重視股價
但是對於基本面而言
會講到那這檔個股
營收這個月到底往上還往下
其實我忘了
好像我好像上個月沒看
就是基本面不見那麼重視
但每天的股價都很重視
為什麼 因為每天就在講哪裡強
你可能常常持股一個禮拜就換
所以這個營收可能一個月再公布一次
可是你持股只有一週
所以老實講
你對基本面根本就不在意
但缺點來講
你就很耐不住正
那不是只有你這檔個股的問題而已
包含大盤出了什麼狀況
美國說了什麼事情
只要指數一拉回
你就會擔心
我買這檔個股可能撐不住
然後就很容易震盪
所以最後慢慢的
就剛剛提到
如果拉長線重視基本面之後
其實最明顯就兩個優勢
第一個就是不怕震盪
你不管發生什麼事情
我都有我的長遠
原本的想法
我常講AI的概念也很簡單
這個一個漏斗下來
其實最重要的前端
就是因為美國四大雲端
業者不斷砸錢
所以自然來要我們家買硬體
這概念不變
所以無論發生什麼事情
我現在投資就是半年後
所謂的資本支出會不會再增加
那這些論點不會因為美伊開戰
不會因為油價轉強
不會因為川普說了什麼事情
就導致我原本的初衷會有所改變
所以中間震盪我並不會害怕
股價波動不代表價值的改變
但很多人把兩件事綁在一起
另外一個更重要
就是長線才有辦法累積財富
這也是我之前
就是我如果剛剛提到
這20年來前10年跟後10年
完全不同的世界
因為前面10年永遠就是
哪裡強往哪裡跑
那特色就是沒有錯
我可以50萬很快就變500萬
可是只要遇到一個狀況
一下子馬上又會回途到
接近原點的位置
那重點就是你必須
你的錢要必須待得住在裡面
我覺得這是很重要的工作
當然講到這個時候
投資人常常講
那個是因為你已經有資金
我沒有資金
你兩三年前就投了
我現在才要進場
對 這兩個問題
第一個呢
我常常講資金喔
我簡單而言
以前我剛入行的時候
也是三五十萬開始
那這是一個重點
第二個我當時也那麼覺得
說會覺得
我剛剛提到
我自己從小部位
一直到法人操作
就是幾億資金在操作
我後來發現
所有的沒有資金大小的問題
操作都是同個邏輯
我們永遠比的都是一個比重
就是我們常常在投資也就問
你現在持股比例是多少
不會有人問你最近買多少
因為每個人的部位不一樣
那你說即使國安基金這麼大的部位
他永遠也是按照的比例下去投資
所以其實投資邏輯跟你的本金有多少
其實並沒有太直接的關係
第二個就是剛剛趙華提到
我們很多人講
那個是因為你兩年前進場的概念
那我們就要繼續往下看
就是講到到底基本面要怎麼去觀察
而且後續的變化要怎麼去瞭解
那我常常講喔
基本面的一個部分
每月每季必做的功課一定要做到
就是所謂的月營收跟季保
這兩個一定要去了解
那即使我常講
就算你操作的時間軸比較短
你的個股可能是一兩週的持股
可是他現在的營收跟獲利
到底怎樣你都有點不太清楚
就很容易被所謂的震出去
所以提到
兩個對比而言
我會覺得營收又比季報
相對來講更重要
因為畢竟啊
雖然說就股東的一個角度
會覺得所謂的季報才有獲利
獲利對股東而言
就是我們投資人而言
才是最重要的工作沒錯
但是有個缺點
因為季報就是每一季三個月才有
那營收的部分
其實有點領先的作用
所以我個人而言
其實我比較重視是
每月的這個營收的一個角度
乖乖的去做這些功課
我常講你不用知道整體的狀況
你不用知道其他人
但你手中持股十檔
你對這十檔現在績效表現如何
你最起碼總該知道
甚至我常講的
買股票可能大家沒概念
你把它想成說你家隔壁的便當店
然後可能鄰居好朋友
他要希望你幫他
他可能資金不夠叫你參股
你說我拿10萬塊
投資在你這家便當店
他每天經過他業績好不好
你總會看一下 好奇一下
你為什麼會投資一家公司
對於他現在營運好壞
你一點概念都沒有
所以我覺得這是很重要的關鍵點
所以一定要了解他目前
到底是慢慢越來越好
還是最近已經開始反轉向下
你才不會抱著這些股票
持續往下一直找不到低點
好 因為你有一些資料很厲害
所以很好奇
你現在到底用到的付費軟體
或者是資料庫
你會比較看哪一些
另外你其實很早
在AI只是會幫忙生成圖的時候
你上達成秀就已經開始用AI做圖了
那現在AI可以做的事情
是不是更多了
應該這樣講
當然我常講
我只要在研究的時間點
我只要電腦打開
永遠都開著AI
然後所有東西一定都靠AI輔助
那當然我們有比較特別的
就是我們有這個所謂的
資料的這個軟體
那這個資料軟體來講
我覺得老實說
我覺得對一般投資人
可能比較不適用
而且我這樣講也不用擔心
我個人覺得雖然不適用
但是也有沒有那個軟體
其實關鍵點並不大
其實真的
我還是回過頭來提到
AI真的可以幫忙
大家非常非常多的事情
其實最重要關鍵點
你要靠著AI要做兩件事
第一個是你自己的訓練
你常講
你要先你的關鍵點在哪裡
是你到底應該問什麼
你要先有個概念
比如說今天
比如說今天大力光很強
我可以買大力光嗎
這個論點通常回答的結果都很爛
你要抽絲剝繭
一層一層的下去問
你一開始可能也許先問說
我就我的角度
一開始就先問
今天大力光為什麼這麼強
對不對 他總會有告訴你幾個原因
然後他告訴你說
我覺得這個時候
可能都還沒有太大幫助
我只講幾個問題舉個例子
比如說他會告訴你
最近大家都認為
他跨入CPO了
那這個時候其實
對投資都還沒有幫助
要繼續問下去
那你說那進入CPO了
他到底在CPO的哪一個段落
那他會告訴你
他中間做了一個光學元件
然後最重要重點
我還是要回歸數字對不對
那你可以問他說
就現在的角度
他的營收開始貢獻了嗎
他就可以幫你統計
他就說
結論就是目前還沒有貢獻
那你就可以繼續問下去
就法人推估跟公司法縮會的說法
他應該會在哪個時間點
營收會慢慢出現
他就會給你一個時間點
這時候我覺得對投資
你還要繼續問下去
你要問他說
那你剛剛這個論點
尤其可能是公司說
有可能是法人說
你要告訴我
你覺得這個
陳真的機會有多少
他如果最後 miss的機會有多少
你的論點是在哪裡
一直一直追問下去
到最後你就知道
這檔股票你應該給它的是一個短線
大家跟題材的投資
還是長線
它真的即將獲利值是我不知道
所以老實講
就是真的可以多找AI幫忙
它無論是在
趨勢面或者是數字面
其實都可以帶給你非常大的幫助
有些我常常遇到投資人
我就講這個論點
他就說
可是他真的不知道
到底怎麼用AI
我只能講一個角度
你面對我的時候
你就一直舉手
所以我可不可以問問題
問問題 問這個怎樣我說你記得你所有舉手問的問題你打開AI跟他對話 你把他當他就是我你怎麼問我 你就怎麼問他他自然就會該有回答 這是第一點
第二點要記得 AI 現在他還是會有具有幻想的問題
他常常會回答一些莫名其妙不太正確的答案
所以你必須要去了解到這個趨勢之外
你必須要有點防措
或者是我常常講的
如果一般投資人
可能沒辦法去辨別
有一個比較好的方式
你把它最起碼去開個
兩到三個這個不同的AI
然後問一樣的問題
甚至抓出來的數字
去對比一下
你就知道到底正不正確
使用一個AI
好像也沒有這麼的容易
但是也是一個
自我訓練的過程
好 剛剛有提到
高持股有信心
大概已經理解的一個原理
但是說實話
每次遇到修正
你都會第一個回答
沒什麼問題
但是沒有什麼問題
要有一個很強的
例如說數據
基本面 未來的願景做支撐
對 我這樣講
先給大家概念
這我自己的論點
我是沒看過市場怎麼解讀
但我以前一直回溯
我的經驗就是
股價會提前市場
最長就是兩季
然後呢
所以代表就以現在八月為例
所以你很多的個股在講
今年會有多厲害
很有可能股價都已經反應
然後這時候投資人
也很擔心說
所以最近在回檔
會不會已經
Party已經全部的結束
我說你如果到07年還在往上
就不可能現在已經全部反應完
因為就是半年的時間
那我們在講
你常會覺得說位階很高
就是因為你對基本面
可能不是很了解
左邊的是營收
右邊的是獲利
只要概念就是
到7月的整體上市過於營收
年增率47
累積前7個月
年增34
第二季剛剛公佈的這個財報
年增140%
然後我常常講
這些當然有激起的問題
但是現在在創立時新高都是真的
這是扎扎實實的數字
那常常會講
這都是已經發生的概念
那我們常常講到底貴不貴
這個是加權指數的本益比走勢
你會發現
沒錯前一段時間在瘋狂的時候
確實有創高
但幅度也不是很大
最近壓回又在原本的整理區間了
那重點呢
這個台股的部分
還是以台積電在帶領
它的獲利EPS
從去年底到現在
這一段增長
就是預估今年的EPS增長
就超過四成以上
所以這都在反映
今年的股價為什麼能夠這麼強
更重要就是台積電
我們就不是只有看本益比
還要再除上它的這個成長率
就是PEG
那可以看到股價藍色的線
不斷走高
但是它的PEG卻持續的走低
就是它股價的漲幅
一直都追不上它的成長力道
所以台積電來講
我常講台積電目前還是
相對比較安全的一檔個股
它安全就代表著指數泡沫的機率
老實講並不高
那我們前段
就是給大家一些
目前看得到的數字
我們再來講一些
剛剛提到的
到底未來
會不會這些都已經反應了
我們再來看未來
前段就提到
台股有一個最大的利益
就是所謂雲端的資本支出
從26 27 28年
每年持續增長
那這些應該這樣講
二六增長九成
明年後年是用猜的
所以有些人會懷疑這個猜的數字
那我只要告訴大家
這是雲端巨頭的所謂的積壓訂單
他們會投入就是因為
他們拿到的訂單在持續噴出
所以他為了要應付這些訂單
必須得投入
所以這個是所謂常常講
訂單是這些所謂投入的領先指標
所以如果一層一層來看
我常常講為什麼我有信心
我看到半年後
我半年後看的什麼
是資本支出
資本支出的前端是什麼
就是這些訂單
所以我個人的論點
你只要這些訂單沒有出現反轉
代表支出不會反轉
代表我們台灣的硬體廠
還在持續走高
所以這個是一層一層的這個概念
回過頭來那是從海外角度
我們回到台股的部分
出口
出口就是扎實的現在的狀況
那也是不斷的在維持高檔創高
那我常常講
這個也是已經發生
我們就看一下外銷訂單
那一樣就是靠電子產品
跟直通訊的部分持續
創歷史新高
那這些都一樣
我剛剛提到
如果就這樣層層的堆疊
等於是台股我們看企業營收
企業營收前面看資本支出
資本支出前看訂單
所以只要回過頭來
無論是剛剛提到
雲端的這些訂單
或者是外銷出口的訂單
只要沒有反轉之前
其他你包含川普
包含聯準會
我覺得那些老江
我覺得都不是那麼重要
好 當然反轉這件事情
你會觀察多久
例如說剛好有一個月
可能外銷訂單的年增率
有點不如預期下來了
或是出口的狀況
有一點點低迷了
我們要怎麼綜合判斷
所謂真正的反轉呢
應該這樣講
從數字面還有包含產業面
也會有一定的相關
因為有一個可能性
就像現在的這個
輝達的這個所謂硬體正在轉換
所以呢
當然有可能會在這個轉換期
導致營收出口的數字稍微掉
所以這塊就要靠著自己的
對產業的了解
因為還沒出現
我就有可能知道有可能會掉
所以代表掉的時候
相對來講我不會那麼恐慌
但是如果今天反向而言
如果現在不是有任何的一個轉變期
應該是一個噴出期
那突然反而出現轉變
那我可能就要花比較多的時間
最後如果找不出原因
我可能就會選擇稍微撤退
以防萬一有反轉的風險
因為都是從基本面出發
市場的資金面
就像你剛剛講的
升不升息 降不降息
你一點都不參考嗎
因為像最近我們有討論到的
可能M1B跟M2的動能也在趨緩
錢再變少
這個您會考慮嗎
不會考慮
因為很簡單的道理
我只給一個中心思想
從2020年到現在
指數漲了四倍
外資賣超了四兆
就是指數會漲
完全是獲利導致的
是因為台積電的獲利漲了8倍
所導致指數漲了4倍
跟誰買誰賣
現在大家會不會害怕
沒有關係
是 好
你看動搖不了他
對我還用到您了
那這邊的話
可能有點問了廢話
但是就是需要
民漢幫我們再度的加強信心
看好的產業跟原因
因為等一下會有檔股票
是今天跌停版的
我想這就是考驗大家信心的時候
但我們先從AI關鍵產品來講
好我們先講喔
這個是台達電
因為它是電子
應該說在AI伺服器的電源供應器
它最主要關鍵點是
市占率超過五成以上
所以它就是產業的龍頭
左邊的圖是告訴大家
電源供應器
它的這個年增長
其實超過100%
會延續在這幾年
綠色點是在台達電
可以看到這邊就是所謂的
它的市占率
從今年開始會超過五成
而且會持續往上
代表著它就是市場龍頭
它說了算
所以常常這樣講
只要他搭上籠頭
代表著AI沒有反轉之前
他都還會持續走高
這個概念理論上
不會有太大變化
所以從三年的營收看到
這就是標準的AI族群
就是每年穩穩的往上
而且每一條線不交跌
這就是我
對這種營收的個股
我都會特別喜愛
那當然股價
從2500跌到1400
但是我覺得對我而言
我就想不要說1400
你跌到400我還是照買
只要這個趨勢不變
我就敢買
這每個人的概念不變
因為我理論上
我就是一個所謂的
基本面為中心思想
他的營收可以創高
他的獲利可以創高
他在AI趨勢上
他又是龍頭
我就不相信
他可以跌到哪裡去
對我而言越跌我越興奮
因為下面我敢買
所以每個人的信念不同
當然很多人看到
現在的這個角度
就沿路破線
而且所有均線
糾結反轉向下
看起來是最慘的時間點
可是我敢買
因為我覺得對基本面
我有比較堅強的信心
另外剛剛提到
今天繼續吃一根跌停的旺席
那一樣概念其實
我常講現在是它的股價很慘
也不會太意外
那我們講長線就好
因為探針卡的部分
它有一個比較明顯的利基
也是市占率過五成
所以也是具有龍頭的地位
那外資 這是外資的預估
這是營收 毛利率
我們看的比較長線
到28年之前
都不會有太大的改變
這是長線
其實它比較重要的關鍵點
就是看到它的營收
因為它的這個所謂的
當時5月的營收大幅的飆升
是 這邊飆
但是這邊就不行了
就開始 對
那你會發現
你可以看到
去年的綠色線差不多
在那個高點之後
因為出貨的量
突然拉高之後
這邊也一樣
對對對
所以本來就會有一點震盪拉回
然後導致應該說
市場看到之前第二季太好
所以本來認為第三季
會再往上噴出
公司的說法很簡單
就是我的產能就只有這麼多
那現在我能產的
已經全部都賣掉
所以未來呢
營收要再增加
就只能調漲價格
跟增加產能
然後第四季才會調漲
這個報價
明年才會再增加產能
所以這需要一點時間
所以目前來講
股價確實就是很弱勢
那應該說目前來講
跌升會反彈
但是這種股票
它就是要等到第四季
所以切記就是反彈的時候
絕對不是你的買點
一樣的問題跌停的時候
進去多少買一點
抱到年底其實是有空間的
因為你每次上來
如果你追在這裡
壓到這裡的時候
你會受不了
所以上去不用買
因為這幾個月業績就是不好
但是要記得這是短線的
它是因為拉貨時間跑
卡在第二季
導致現在動能降低
但是重點在需求的部分
完全沒有任何改變
好 但我們要如何知道
像台達電
我們也是從你講的
四五百 三四百就開始看
怎樣叫做本益比合理
對不對 然後例如旺系也是啊
不到一千 看到他漲到七千多又修正
可是我怎麼知道他是不是已經把未來的
都能漲完這件事
到底要怎麼評估那個平衡點
好 這個趙華如果有這個問題
用AI是不是
不是 不是 我覺得這個問題
要符合這個條件
只有台積電可以
就是他維持高成長
那本益比一直在合理範圍之內
那這個你就只能買台積電
如果這些AI強勢族群
我不是講股價
我是說基本面強勢的AI股
其實現在的股片的問題
已經沒辦法去評價
它該有的價格
本益比都已經創歷史新高
那應該說我們就以台達電為例
以前它本益比就是一二十倍
那前一段時間飆到五十幾倍
接近六十倍
那回過頭來
如果你每一次呢
就覺得不合理你就出場
其實不到三十倍你就出場
你等於說不到一千塊
你就再也不可能
再買到這檔股票
那常常的問題
就是說是不是已經提前反應
我剛剛講有可能
所以你要有心理準備
萬一你買在最高點
你最長最長
我剛剛提到股價就是
最多反應半年
所以最多就是等到半年後
發現他的獲利還在創高
自然又會在創高
所以中間你要有心理準備
最慘就是可能會被套一到兩劑
那中間你就必須要
有耐心的持續買進
但買進的過程當中
你要持續盯著他的營收跟獲利
不能反轉
不能反轉向下
你就閉著眼睛買
這也是錯誤的
你第一 長線趨勢對
第二 下來敢買
第三 你要做好功課
營收獲利還在成長
這段時間只要耐得住
這關痛苦期
未來等到它創高之後
你永遠都是買在最低點
好 今天謝謝明翰
我覺得觀眾應該是很羨慕我們
明翰叫我們問AI
我都直接問AI達人
而且跟他擄他都不厭其煩
動搖不了他
其實就跟你看的縣途一樣
我問他縣途的時候
也動搖不了他
他的基準就是看
以憲徒為主
所以今天如果憲不好
也動搖不了你
就是不好
兩位的信念都是無可動的